Adele, how you doing, man?
>> I'm doing good. Asalama alalaykum.
>> Salamsei.
>> How are you doing?
>> I'm good. Are you a Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm from uh Dagistan, Russia.
>> And you're a Muslim? How long you been a
Muslim?
>> My whole life. My parents were Muslim.
>> You grew up Muslim?
>> Why? Cuz I'm white.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> I'm from, you know, like part of Russia
and there's Slavic and there's Bosnian
and stuff. My father's Bosnian, my mom's
Russian. I grew up in Russia.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Cool. So, what
what's your thoughts, man? I know you
ready. You've been you've been here
waiting patiently for a little bit.
>> I have. I have. Uh, nothing. I just have
a question. So, you say that Jesus is
the most He's God. Like, he's the
Almighty.
>> He's the most high God. That's right.
>> Did Jesus in the Bible prayed? He
prayed, right?
>> He sure did.
>> So, in other words, God prayed.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So,
>> you think that's a problem? Well, yeah,
cuz when you pray, you either worship
and you worship and you seek knowledge
or or you seek wisdom or you seek
forgiveness, right?
>> Not necessarily. I would say worship.
Sure.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, God worship someone.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. God worshiping someone. Who is God
worshiping?
>> Let me ask you. So, let me let me Okay.
So, if God is multi-personal
>> Mhm.
>> the persons within the Godhead can pray
and worship and adore each other.
There's no problem with that. If God is
uni personal, meaning he's only one
person,
>> but they share the same nature. They
share the same share the same nature.
>> They share the same nature and all of
that. That's absolutely right. That
doesn't negate hold on Adele. That
doesn't negate that they can worship and
adore each other. There's no problem.
They're distinct persons, so they can do
that. But they're not they're not
worshiping or adoring another god
outside of themselves. They're adoring
each other within within the essence of
God. You have this fellowship and
communion of love and adoration.
>> So they can do that with each other.
>> Yes. But they're they're still
worshiping. Why would they have to
worship one another if they all
>> It's not It's not a have to.
>> Relax, brother. If they all share the
same What's funny,
>> you dreamed of this moment, haven't you?
>> What do you mean?
>> Go ahead, bro. Go ahead. I'm Looks like
we're having a good time here.
>> I'm coming here with love and respect,
brother. Nothing.
>> Same here. Same here. I like you. Don't
Don't get me wrong. I I like your entire
demeanor and your attitude. I trust me.
So go ahead. I'm listening. Thank you.
So if they share the same I lost my
train of thought. If they share the same
nature,
>> why would one another have to
communicate? Why would one another have
to see worship or um pray to one
another?
>> Would you say would you agree that
worship is an act of love?
>> Sure.
>> So if within the essence of God the
persons
share and cooperate in perfect love.
>> Okay.
>> It shouldn't surprise us that the
persons would worship each other and
give adoration towards each other in
that way. But that's God. That's a
godlike nature.
>> But what is a godlike nature?
>> Apparently praying and worshiping.
>> Yeah. Pray prayer is just communication
with the divine. Bro,
>> really? So the Holy Spirit prays?
>> Yep. Let me let me ask you this. What
does the word salat mean?
>> Uh, pardon?
>> The word salat. It's Arabic.
>> I'm not here to debate Islamic
scriptures. I want to use logic from the
Bible.
>> I know, but you're if you're going to
use an argument against me, you got to
be consistent.
>> I'm not I'm using a biblical argu I'm
using all stuff from the Bible. I'm not
using anything from
>> No, you're not. You're doing you're
you're critiquing my position, but
you're you're critiquing my position as
if there's something wrong with the idea
of God praying or God worshiping.
>> Yeah. Because if you claim that you're
the Almighty, the one above all, who are
you praying to? Why are you
>> Exactly. So, so do you see how your you
your position is you cannot be God and
pray. You cannot be God and worship
another.
>> That's your position. So that's why I'm
asking you, you have to be consistent as
a Muslim to bring these objections. You
cannot be a hypocrite, right? When we
bring arguments, these arguments can't
backfire against us or it's a bad
argument.
>> Yeah. It just morally I I just believe
that I'm not able to debate Islamic
scriptures and personal things from
Islam because I think that people who
debate specific scriptures, you have to
study it. You have to know it. You have
to have the the proper philosophy to do
that morally. That's not something I can
do. and I don't think I have the
intellectual capability of doing that.
>> All right, fair enough. That's okay. So,
I won't argue this to you. I'll just
show you what I'm talking about. Okay,
>> go ahead.
>> Okay, so the word salat in Arabic, it
means prayer. Okay. And salawat is the
plural form of salat. It means prayers.
Okay? So, when we go to the Quran, I'm
showing you why this argument backfires.
When we go to the Quran in chapter 2,
there's a verse in there that says that
the prayers of your Lord are on the
believers. That Allah prays for the
believers. Okay? So, let me show you
this really quick. It's in chapter 2.
Chapter 2. I'll pull it up on the screen
so we can all look at it, too. Now, a
lot of English translations try to hide
this and try to translate it as
blessing, but blessing in Arabic is
baraka, not salat. Salat is prayer. When
you go perform salat, when you go do
your salat prayer, that's prayer, right?
[snorts] Baraka is blessing. So, some of
them try to mix it up, but they they
can't get away with it. All right, so
let's see. Uh, what what verse was that?
It two 253. Let's see. Uh,
I'm having a brain fart. 2157. Thank
you. 2157. There it is. All right. 215
album. All right. So, I'll show it on
the screen and I'm going to show you
what the English says, but I'm going to
show you what the Arabic says. Okay?
>> There's no point to show me what the
English says. If you think it's if
you're just going to say it's corrupt
and they're trying to change the
meaning, there's no that adds nothing to
the argument.
>> Okay, I got you. Whoops. Oh, I'm not
sharing my screen. Hold on. Let me uh
make this bigger. Okay. All right. So,
this is chapter 2 verse 157. It says,
"These un them are." You see, you say
you don't care about the English. I'm
glad you said that. But as these on them
are the salawatun,
prayers mean rahim from their lord and
mercy. Right? And they it is who are
guided. So it says that Allah has his
prayers
on those who are guided.
>> Sure. This is why I don't debate
scriptures is because in my opinion if
I'm were to debate scriptures and I feel
like this something every religion
agrees upon is that you need to know the
entire chapter. You need to know the
entire verse. You can't just debate
specific scriptures because there's
context that is missing. I don't know
that context. So I can't help you with
this statement right here. That's why I
don't touch scriptures specific.
>> No, it's okay. So I'm saying if you're
going to argue that God cannot pray,
then that means that Allah is not God
because he prays in the Quran. Well, no,
because I'm not giving you a specific
scripture. I'm giving you something that
physically happened. A story being told
from the Bible. The story being told
that Jesus kneelled to the ground and
worshiped and prayed to his father. He
prayed to God when
>> Yeah. You're saying you're saying that
that disqualifies his divinity when it
doesn't. But if you're going to go with
that, if you're saying that that
disqualifies his divinity, you have to
say Allah is not God then.
>> Well, no. Well, no, not at all. Because
I'm not I'm not We're using You're using
a specific scripture and I'm using I'm
not using scripture. I'm using
>> You are You're using scripture. There's
a story.
>> No, I'm using a story. Did I Did I
directly quote the Bible?
>> Yeah. Well, you didn't give me a verse,
but you're pulling from the Bible,
right?
>> Exactly. I'm pulling a story from the
Bible, obviously. Yes.
>> Yes. But am I missing out context of
what I said about Jesus praying?
>> No.
>> Exactly.
Do I believe that you're missing out
context of what Allah said in that
statement? Yes, I do. Because I
>> Because you're using a specific
scripture. I'm using a spec a moment.
>> Yeah. But hold on. Why? Why do you think
I'm quoting this out of context?
>> I I don't believe that you're quoting
out of context. It's a very good It was
a very good point that you brought up,
but I cannot debate against that because
I don't know the full story as as
>> I know. So, what I'm saying is Adele,
what I'm saying is is that you should
not use this argument. It's a bad
argument. If you're going to say that
Jesus praying and worshiping the father
shows that he's not God, then you're
going to have to say that when Allah
prays, he's not God according to that
same standard. Yes. So either either you
be consistent, say Allah is not God or
drop the argument. It's a bad one.
>> No. No. Because I came here. I'm saying
I'm not here to debate Islam. I'm using
logic from the Bible. Is your Okay.
Wait. You as a Christian, is your job to
disprove the Quran or is is your job to
prove the Bible?
>> Both.
>> Well, just the Bible. Just not. No.
You're supposed to prove that your God
is the one and only. You're not supposed
to disprove other gods.
>> I'm supposed to disprove other gods. The
Bible literally tells me to bring all
falsehood under Christ. disprove it.
Contend against it.
>> If that's a direct quote, then I'm
mistaken.
>> That's okay. So, so listen. I I want to
know where you're at now. Are you going
to be consistent and say that Allah is
not God or are you brother here's I need
to read the full scripture. It's against
my I need to read the full chapter,
brother.
>> So, at least So, for now, can we drop
the argument that Jesus praying uh
disqualifies him from being God? That we
we can drop that argument for now,
right?
>> Well, I have nothing else to talk about.
I just came here to ask this specific
question. I can't.
>> No, what I'm saying is, brother, listen
to what I'm what I'm saying. Your
argument didn't work because of what we
see in the Quran. It doesn't work. All
right. Unless if you want to keep it,
dude. Adele, it's really simple.
>> But what what if I wasn't Muslim? And if
I wasn't Muslim,
>> but you are.
>> No, but Okay, but if I wasn't Muslim, if
I wasn't Islam, what would you tell me?
>> If you if you leave Islam, I'll give you
that spoiler alert.
>> Islam. I'm not leaving Islam. And then
then I
>> No, you're dancing around, brother.
You're dancing, brother. You're running
circles around what I'm saying right
now. If I
>> How would you combat what I'm saying?
Because if if there's a divine nature
and they all share the same soul and you
you don't pray from your flesh, you pray
from your soul. Correct.
>> There's no praying from soul or flesh.
It's just a person prays. You know,
you're
>> you as a person.
>> Yeah. You just a person who pray for
your soul.
>> If you want to say that that a person is
soul and that's the equals, fine. I I
don't
>> Yeah. Well, you you get what I mean? You
pray from your essence. You pray from
your nature. You pray from your soul.
>> You're just a person who prays, brother.
>> So Jesus was just a person who prayed.
>> He's a person who prays, just like Allah
is a person who prays.
>> Okay. I need to read the full chapter
and full scripture.
>> Okay. So with that being said, can I
show you other things that demonstrate
that Jesus is God?
>> I mean, sure. Go ahead.
>> Cool. So um let me ask you, how much of
the Quran have you read?
>> Bits and pieces. I never fully read it
front to cover, but my parents told me
the stories I need to know and I take
part in fasting and I try to read as
much Quran as I know and I try to study
upon it.
>> Okay. So, I'm going to show you a verse.
Um, and I'm what I'm going to do is is
I'm going to show you that from the
Quran standards when we go to the when
we look at the Bible that Jesus even
qualifies to be God from the Quranic
standards.
>> And one of the reason the things I'm
going to show you is uh the titles and
names that Allah applies to himself. All
right. You're familiar with Allah having
the 99 names, his attributes, right?
These are things that are unique to him
alone, right? That identify him as God.
Okay. So, I'm going show you what's one
of these.
>> You can bring it up, but I'm not
debating scriptures.
>> I'm not telling you to debate. I'm just
trying to show you.
>> Perfect. So, we're just having
conversation.
>> We're just having conversation. This
isn't no, oh, Adele got cooked. No, this
ain't none of that.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> We're just chilling. We talking.
>> Perfect.
>> All right. Okay. So this is going to I'm
going to show you chapter 57 verse 24 of
the Quran and then I'm going to show you
a Bible verse on the side of it. Okay.
Good.
>> Not 57 verse 24. 573. My goodness. What
is wrong with my brain right now? All
right. Let's put this over here. No, no,
no. Let's keep this here. Oops. Let's
keep that there. Let's bring Let's bring
the Bible. Let's get the Bible up over
here. Let's bring up the Bible.
>> All right.
>> Your chat saying I'm not a Muslim.
>> What do you have to say to that? Do they
want me to read out a surah?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Probably quote surf like
just the like first few
I don't know about that.
>> Well, I'm not Arabic, so maybe my
pronunciation isn't the best. But Allah
says that the people who still try and
um who have good intentions and try
their best, they get double the rewards.
So,
>> okay. Okay. Would you be upset if
somebody put a beat to that? How you
just recited that like that?
>> Oh, do you want me to sing it? Do you
want me to do how like how like the
imams do it?
>> No. No, you don't have to. You could
though, huh?
>> Yeah, I could.
>> Do you listen to music?
>> Yeah, but some I'm not saying I'm a
perfect Muslim. Hold up.
>> Oh, something happened. He probably got
a call. He was rapping that thing, man.
All right, while we wait for him to come
back, let's go ahead and get to some
more super chats. Super chats. DG says
he says it's impossible to change the
word of Allah. Yet nearly in the same
sentence says the English may not be
interpreted correctly. God help them.
[clears throat] Yeah. Oh, you're back.
Okay. All right. So, here we go, man.
So, we got over here on the right, we
got the Quran. Over here on the left, we
got the Bible. I'm going to show you the
Quran. You're muted, by the way. So, it
says
>> salami.
So, so the Quran over here, chapter
57:3, it says about Allah, he is the
first and the last, the outward and the
inward. He has knowledge of everything.
We're going to focus right here on this
title right here. He is the first and
the last. Meaning that he is eternal,
the infinite one, right? Always existed
and will never end. Jesus over here says
the same thing. He says, "I am the Alpha
and the Omega, the first and the last,
the beginning and the end." So Jesus
makes the same claim that Allah makes
600 years later in the
>> Jesus claims to be God in your book.
>> Wait, say that again. What' you say?
>> In the Bible, Jesus claims to be God.
Yeah.
>> What did he say? Yeah. Yes, you're
right.
>> But I don't believe in the Bible.
>> Why not?
>> Because I just don't believe in it.
>> No. Uh-uh. I ain't good enough.
>> I haven't read the Bible. I've grown up
my life as a Muslim. I learned the I
learned the traditions of a Muslim and
I'm asking you questions to get to
possibly open my mind to Christianity.
Brother, I don't know why your chat is
so mean to me. I'm hearing it with love
and respect. Yeah, let me let me say let
me address the chat. Chat, guys, be nice
to the brother. He came up. He had the
bravery to come up. While the actual DA
scholars don't, they never come up to
the platform. He had enough, you know,
courage to come up and have a
conversation. So, let's show grace here.
Like, you don't have to be a bearded man
to be a part of the Muslim religion.
Like, are Muslim? There's Russians that
are Muslim. Like, you don't you don't
have to be a bearded man to be Muslim.
>> There we go.
>> You really don't.
>> All right. So, with that being said,
guys, in the chat, I need you guys do
not be a stumbling block, okay? He's
willing to listen. He's not hard-headed.
He can have a logical conversation.
Let's be let's be gentle with him and
loving. All right? Let's be Christlike.
All right?
>> I didn't say Jesus is God. I said in the
Bible he claims to be God. Does heible?
>> He's being honest. Yes, he does. He very
clearly claims to be God in the Bible.
He just doesn't believe the Bible. That
see at least we could get that out of
the brother that he was very honest. We
didn't have to play games. We didn't
have to go on roller coaster rides. He
said, "Yeah, Jesus claims to be God in
the Bible. I I don't believe the Bible
though." Simple. That's honest. Now,
let's talk about why you should believe
the Bible. Okay. Let's talk about why
you should believe the Bible. You're a
Muslim, Adele. You're a Muslim, right?
Yes.
>> Okay. This is what your Quran says. Your
Quran says that the Bible is a
revelation of Allah. The Torah and the
Gospel are re You said claim all books.
Yes.
>> Right. So that's why you should believe
in the Bible. If you don't, you're going
against your Quran. You get what I'm
saying?
>> I have to read the whole chapter.
>> Read the whole chapter of what?
>> Of when that verse was said,
>> bro. What? Dude, look. Look, man. What
you're gonna learn here as we continue
our developing friendship is that the
only thing that I'mma ever do is I'mma
just read, bro. Heard it before. I've
been in your life.
>> You've heard it before. So, we going to
read. I'm Everything that I say is
verbatim what the Quran says. It's not
going to be anything different. Okay.
Look. So, obviously, we'll go to verse
we'll go to chapter 3 real quick.
Chapter 3 and 4. All right. Uh see
[clears throat] what this says here.
Okay. So, there chapter 3 and 4. That's
what it says. He has sent down upon you
the book with truth confirming what was
before it. And he sent down the Torah
and the Gospel. Right? Very clear. The
Torah and Gospel is revelation of Allah.
You we cannot deny it. You You don't
need a whole chapter to tell you that.
You got it in this verse. Right. Okay.
Now,
>> when we continue to read,
>> but wait, can I I just have a question?
>> Yeah. So the original Torah, the
original like the the first ever
original Torah, the first ever original
Bible, are they the same as we have
today?
>> Yes, the same as we have today.
>> Is there proof for that?
>> Well, the Quran says it. I told you I'm
going just read the Quran. The Quran did
all the work for me, bro.
>> So, watch this. It says, "And believe in
that which I have sent down to you."
Talking about the Quran, confirming that
which is with you. So, in Muhammad's
time, it's still with them.
>> The scriptures are still with them. The
Quran is saying it confirms them,
meaning they're true, right? Paying
attention. I feel like you're too
focused on the chat, man. Are you paying
attention or not?
>> No, I'm I'm paying attention and
listening to exactly what you're saying.
The chat's over here.
>> Okay. So, we h we have here where the
Quran is saying that these scriptures
are still with them in Muhammad's time.
>> Brother, you're just reading me Quran
again. I you can you can send me
>> You believe the Quran, right? You
believe the Quran, right?
>> I do. Yes, I do believe the Quran.
>> Okay. Yes. But you're reading me the
Quran, but I'm telling you for me to
respond, I'd have to read the whole
chapter. So, if you want, you can send
me these and I'll study them on my own
time.
>> Okay, we'll do that. Um, you got a pen
or some something you can take notes on
real quick? I I'll give you just a few
verses. I won't overload you. I'll give
you a few a few verses you can look at
and then come back. Okay.
>> Are you ready?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Chapter 3, verse 3 and 4.
>> Chapter 2, verse 41.
>> Chapter 2, verse uh verse 44.
>> Yep.
>> Chapter 2, verse 89.
>> Okay. Chapter 2 verse 91.
>> Perfect.
>> Chapter 2 verse 101.
>> Chapter 10 verse 94.
>> Say that again.
>> Chapter 10 verse 94. I'll leave you with
those. That's good enough.
>> Thank you.
>> Check those and uh we'll talk again next
time. Okay.
>> Yeah. You want me to come back to you?
Okay. It was a pleasure talking to you,
man. Thank Thank you for giving me the
time of day. Thank you for coming with
love and respect.
>> Of course. You too, man. Take care. All
right.
>> I'll see you.
>> Peace. All right. All right. Well, all
we could do is pray for the brother. All
we can do is pray for him. Hopefully
that uh you know he's real and sincere.
If he's not, that's on him. We got to do
what God ain't on us. That ain't on us,
man. All right, let's bring up AJ
Muhammad. How you doing, bro?
>> Hey, bro. Can you hear me? Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Sorry. It's AJ Ahmed. Um yeah,
good to good to connect, Avery. How you
doing?
>> Good to connect, man.
>> Yeah, you're all good. Yeah. So, um the
topic that you had is Jesus is the most
high, right? So,
>> that's right.
>> And you call yourself God logic. So, I'm
going to try to keep it logical. Yeah.
Just so it's all clear for everyone.
Cool. So, if Jesus is the most high, why
does he refer uh to the most high or why
is he referred to as the son of the most
high? Because where it gets confusing
for me, the most high is the son of the
most high. So, for me, that's like a
paradox.
>> Indeed, it is a paradox. But there's
nothing wrong with paradoxes.
>> What's the definition of paradox? Isn't
it? You're saying that son of the most
high? A paradox is not a contradiction.
If it was a contradiction, then we had a
problem. A paradox is just something
that is like really deep, has a lot of
mystery to it. It seems like there's
opposing views, but it's really not.
That's what a paradox is.
>> So, it being a paradox is not a problem
for you.
>> Of course not.
>> Okay. So, so you agree that the son of
the most high is also the most high.
>> Yes. The son of the most high is also
the most high himself.
>> Okay. So when we say the son and son is
that Jesus is the son of the most high
the reference there to most high is the
father and when and Jesus is also
identified as the most high because he
shares the same essence and nature as
the father. So by nature Jesus is the
most high.
>> Okay. So is there a specific reason why
um like it's mentioned the son of the
most high? Why is why is the the most
high be mentioned as the son of the most
high?
>> Wait, ask your question again. I'm
sorry.
>> So why is the father being referred to
as the most high
>> in the Bible?
>> Because he is the most high by nature.
>> So So he's higher than the most high.
They're both high, brother.
>> This conversation is high as well. So,
I'm just trying to get this right.
>> It is. It is.
>> Okay. So, so this is where like I
started off the conversation with
>> if Jesus is the most high and the father
are the most high, then they're both
equally high.
>> So, when compared to each other, they
can't be the most high.
>> They're they're equally the most high,
brother.
>> So, but but the the direct comparison or
direct reference in in the Bible is the
son of the most high. So we're not
comparing it to to the rest of the
world.
>> Jesus is also called the most high. AJ
>> in the Bible. Yeah. If you can quote
that.
>> Yeah. So in Daniel 7, the ancient of
days, which is the father, and the son
of man, which is Jesus, are both said to
be rulers, right? And they're both
referred to as the most high. Okay. So,
let's bring you over here. Have you ever
read Daniel before, the prophet?
>> No.
>> No. Okay, cool. I like showing people
new things. All right. Have you um heard
of the term son of man before?
>> Son of son of man.
>> Yeah, the son of man.
>> Maybe not in the context that you mean,
but I'm trying to understand it from the
the words.
>> Okay, I'll just show you. Um
I'll show you. Okay, let me do it this
way. All right, I'm going to be over
here on the Wait, no, I'll do it right
here. Actually, you over here. Okay, so
this is Daniel 7. Starting in verse 9.
It says, "As I looked," This is Daniel
speaking. As I looked, thrones were
placed. And the ancient of days took his
seat. So multiple thrones were placed.
More than one thrones were placed. One
of them belonged to the ancient of days
took his seat. His clothing was white as
snow, and the hair of his head like pure
wool. His throne was fiery flames. Its
wheels were burning fire. A stream of
fire issued and came out from before
him. And thousands thousands served him.
and 10 thousands time 10 thousands stood
before him. The court sat in judgment
and the books were opened. All right. So
the ancient of days is one of the
rulers. That's who we identify as the
father. Okay. All right. And we
continue. We'll jump down to verse 13
for sake of time. It says, "I saw in the
night visions." He continues, "And
behold, with the clouds of heaven there
came one like a son of man, and he came
to the ancient of days and he and was
presented before him. and to him was
given dominion and glory and a kingdom
that all peoples, nations, and languages
should serve him. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away and the kingdom one that shall
not be destroyed. So the remember when
thrones were placed, the ancient of days
took his seat. Well, the the other
throne belongs to the one like the son
of man. Okay. So, these are the two
rulers, the son of man and the ancient
of days. You with me so far?
>> Yep.
>> Now, watch this. When we go here, we
scroll down a bit. Now, everybody's
serving, right? Everybody is serving the
the ancient of days and serving the son
of man. Everybody, all the creatures in
heaven, all the people of the earth,
every nation, tongue, they're serving
the son of man and the ancient of days.
All right. Now, watch this. It says,
"But the saints of the most high shall
receive the kingdom and possess the
kingdom forever and ever." The saints of
the most high. Now, here's what's
interesting. When you go to the Aramaic,
cuz Daniel's the Daniel 7 is written in
Aramaic. The word for most high here,
you see how in the English it has it as
just most high, like singular.
>> Yep.
>> But in the Aramaic, which I got over
here on the left, I'm going to zoom in
so we can see it too. In verse 18, it's
actually in the plural. The word here.
Here it is right here. Uh, most high.
Elonin. The singular form of this is
Elon. The in Elonin. That makes it
plural. And as you can read it, it says
adjective masculine plural. Okay. So,
the original language, it's actually the
most highs. Elonin. So, why is the
translation on that page also the most
high? No, not not this one on the left.
So the one that's translating the
Aramaic, why does that say the most
high?
>> I I don't know.
>> It's it's context. So you were doing the
same with the Quran. If the linguistics
of Aramaic and the specialists are
giving you the definition, what gives me
you the right to be like, no, means
multiple most highs. The same way with
Islam when you mention in the Quran if
the linguistic if the Arabic specialists
who specialize in linguistics say in
this context it means this why do we
argue with them?
>> Well I'm not arguing with anybody. Um
the English rendering is is incorrect
here. It's not singular. It's plural.
It's el like we we we can't argue with
that. So when the original language when
the original language has it in the has
it in the plural it's most highs. That's
what it is. That's just what it is in
the in the in the um sorry in the uh
Aramaic. Now with that being said, of
course, like you said, right, you said
context. According to context, who are
the people serving? Who are the who's
being served by all peoples?
>> Yeah. But I I also believe that saints
>> just really quick if you can if you can
answer that. Yeah. But of the high
>> Yeah. Yeah. The saints of the who are
the who are the ones that they're
serving and and rece uh having a share
in the kingdom with who who is it that
they serve
>> in the most high. Is that what you're
trying to say?
>> Yeah. But who specifically? Remember we
looked up before
>> the two that you mentioned earlier.
>> So according to the context, there's two
that have the ultimate rulership. That's
the ancient of days and the son of man.
Right.
>> Yeah. But the saints of the most high.
This is singular.
>> No, it's it's plural, brother. It's I
just showed you right here. Look, I have
it right here. I even made it bigger for
you. It's plural in the in the Aramaic.
Matter of fact, let me show you this. If
we go to verse 25, it uses both the
singular and the plural. Here's the
here's the singular form of it. And and
words speak words against the most high.
This is singular. Il la singular
masculine singular,
>> right?
>> He shall speak in the saints. Here it is
again. Of the most highs, Elonin plural.
It uses both the singular and the plural
in the same verse.
>> Okay, one second. So, he shall speak
most high. Um, the the English doesn't
>> he shall it says he shall speak and the
saints of the most high shall persecute.
So, he's going to p he so he's going to
speak against the most high and
persecute the saints of the most highs.
So you notice how it can use like the
Daniel's not, you know, silly. He knows
the difference between the singular most
high and the plural most high. He uses
both.
>> So you So you think people have just
been translating it incorrectly until at
what point did you realize that they've
been translating it incorrectly? Is it
just from research?
>> Yeah. When we go to the original
language and it's in plural, not
singular, but they're translating it in
the singular. It's plural, bro. Okay.
But are you This is where I get
confused. Are you an expert in Aramaic?
What if it means the most high based on
the context?
>> It doesn't. It's plural. Even Even the
experts the experts who give us the site
say it's in the it's an adjective
masculine plural. Even the experts tell
us this. So I don't it's not me making
this up.
>> Okay. Um like let me just um give you
another point. Like for example, maybe
it doesn't make sense uh to you, but I
use it when I'm speaking. So when
somebody asks me, "Where is your
granddad?" Like, and I say they've gone
to the shop, there's one, right? It's
still a masculine plural. Um but it's
talking referring to one person in that
context. So when somebody says, "Where's
your granddad?" Oh my. Because I
normally use out of respect. I don't say
he. I say they even though it's a single
person.
I don't believe you. That that would
that would uh one I don't believe that
that's how you talk. Two, that would be
incorrect grammar to say they when
talking about a singular person, your
granddad. There's no such thing as as
plural of majesty in English. Like
>> Exactly. So in English like that.
>> Exactly. So in English So in English, it
doesn't make sense. But in Arabic,
that's the case. Not the case either. In
Arabic, you have the singular and the
plural for for singular persons as well.
You don't do that.
>> No. No. where we have single and plural,
but there's times where you use plural
out of respect.
>> No, you don't.
>> Okay. If you're going to disagree there,
then we have to disagree. But anyone
>> that's fine, but that that doesn't
explain that doesn't help you explain
this where most high is plural and in
the context we see that the son of the
son of man and the ancient of days are
the ones who are ruling and being served
by everyone. So
>> no even I can grant that in terms of
like it's mentioned that it's the most
high but this is where I get even more
confused. I tried to keep it logical. So
the book that was mentioning son of the
most high that's a separate book to the
book that you just showed me now right
now. Right. Or is that part of the same
Bible?
>> It's it's in it's the same Bible. It's
just a different book in the Bible.
>> And was it written by a different
person?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's the bit where it gets very
hard to compare because one person is
saying son of the cuz one person is
saying son of the most high and then
somebody else is disagreeing. He's
saying
>> that's not a disagreement. They're both
the most high. He's and and if you're
talking about their relation with each
other, one of the persons is the son of
the other, but they're both the both the
most high uh in regards to their
essence. There's no problem.
>> Yeah. We have to assume that they're
both on the same page even though
they're from separate books.
>> Yeah, they are. There's nothing that
they say that's contradictory.
>> Yeah, I I I think I get your point, but
it's very hard for me to understand from
a logical point of view why you would
even mention son of the most high if you
are the most high.
>> Well, if because if if the most high is
multi-personal, the father, son, and
holy spirit, the father is the most
high, the son is also the most high, the
son is begotten from the father.
>> So you can call Jesus rightly so the son
of the most high. That's a true
statement of the father. Um, and it's
also true that Jesus is the most high
himself, sharing the same essence of the
father. There's nothing there's nothing
>> wrong. Exactly. So, it's just a use of
title. So, if if me and you were both
the strongest and then I was referred to
as the son of the most strongest, I
would be kind of like upset because
we're both the strongest. So, why would
you use that to the kind of
>> But but do you but do you see how you
see how it's not contradictory? Like
even even if you personally would take
offense to that for some reason, that
doesn't mean that it's a contradiction.
Can we agree with that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I would I would say it's a
paradox. Not sensible.
>> But
>> you said it's nonsensible.
>> So not sensible to use that. It wouldn't
be sensible. It wouldn't be sensible for
me to say
>> is it a is it a contradiction, bro?
>> I would say it's not logical. Like it
doesn't make sense.
>> So just just to be clear cuz I'm asking
a very straightforward question. No, I
agree that that you can be um that two
people can be the tallest in a group,
but when you're comparing them both, you
can never say that one's the tallest
because you're referring to them both.
But if you're comparing a room full of
people,
>> let me let me ask you this. If you have
a room if you have a room full of people
>> and the highest height is 6'11.
>> Yep.
>> You got two people that are 6'11. A dad
and his son.
>> Yeah.
>> Are they both the tallest? Yeah, that's
just what that's exactly what I just
said.
>> Can you Can you call one person the son
of the tallest?
>> No, cuz they're both the tallest. Why
Why would you use that to differentiate?
>> Hey, bro. I think that when it comes to
the deity of Christ and this Bible
stuff, man, by the way, you're a Muslim,
right?
>> Yeah, I'm Muslim.
>> Yeah, I knew it.
>> By the way, I just have a side comic
>> because let me Yeah. Yeah. because
you're a Muslim. Um, it's you you have
this automatic refusal to acknowledge
when something in Christianity makes
sense. You have to reach anywhere you
can to try to to to not admit that,
okay, yeah, this this this is pretty
consistent. Um, let's move on. No,
instead you're going to you're going to
insist and sit and no, it just doesn't
make sense even when something is
clearly making sense. You will say the
opposite for the for the sake of not
acknowledging that Christ that something
in Christianity makes sense. That's what
that's what you guys do, man. It's
really crazy.
>> But but it's human logic. So I'm
assuming by your name, God logic, you
have a bit of higher understanding than
my human logic, right? So my
>> Thanks for coming. Take care of
yourself, big